citizens the reject Nation we are here
to watch from new rock stars Miss
Clemens chihook episode 9 Easter eggs
and breakdown and with an episode like
this I bet there are plenty of Easter
eggs we all missed while reacting to
this John how are you I am so excited
how are you good good good John I just
shot a reaction for Halloween ends I
feel like this is the exact audience is
going to want to check out
ladies come check out a Halloween oh my
God you're gonna botch your reaction I
know Halloween kills has just got that
ring to it and also corjandro just had a
video go up here on the channel of
ranking all the Marvel Disney Plus shows
I think it's a really worthwhile video
go ahead and check that out all right
let's get into it but before we do leave
a like that's the last thing I gotta say
let's go
[Music]
I know life is rough welcome back to New
rockstars I'm Jessica Clemens here to
break down episode nine aka the finale
of she-hulky smash their own episode not
so much happened so many new crazy
appearances I guess everyone's a dad now
on the MCU there's Daddy's Galore Jen
could change Kevin's creation which
means maybe Deadpool can too now like
let's just get into it because I'm still
spiraling I'm immediately gonna say that
I I pray in real life that Kevin feige
actually approved a script and didn't re
I saw your Tweet yeah I was trying to
recount my tweet I totally forgot it was
like fantasy
it was perfectly worked here it is
there's my tweet I like it that's why
you can't just regurgitate a joke you've
already made I'm not a professional
stand-up comedian I don't know how to do
that that's the best way to make a joke
and then explain it before the Marvel
logo and song stop the Marvel Studios
logo starts to Twitch and frizz out a
red screen reads danger and it's
mimicking the 1978 opening to the whole
TV series frame for Frank and now we
also see the scene from the trailer of
70s Jen and Bruce and where it came from
that's right we did see the commercials
one of the earlier episodes on the news
that we know is from The Incredible Hulk
when Jen transforms into She-Hulk in
this intro I think it's the onset
She-Hulk reference Malia Aria I might be
wrong but it might be her Jen working I
also think results in illustration we
see with her in the shield files at the
end of every episode the narrator refers
to her as the Savage She-Hulk a call
back to the Savage She-Hulk comics from
the 80s this is the first run of
She-Hulk where through a lot of turmoil
Jen becomes a Hulk almost dies does
permanently decided to be a She-Hulk and
a lot of stuff just happens also they
call it Savage because she's a science
because she wakes up in the same prison
a meal was in in Prior episodes episode
two and three to be exact at the dodc
Mallory pug and Nikki like the great
friends they are checking in on Jen and
reveal to her a plea deal she has to
wear an inhibitor we've seen the
inhibitor before we've seen it with Hulk
we've seen it with a meal and now Jen
has it which you know clearly sucks
because we know from episode three a
meal can still change into abomination
in that cell and even clearly mad
talking to Mallory about it Jen doesn't
change into She-Hulk she can clearly
control her anger this is also sort of
mirrors everything that happens to a
Mill and out of control moment witnessed
by others furthering the notion that
you're still a walking Hazard so Jen
starting right now has relinquished her
ability to change back into She-Hulk
which sucks yeah you see I like the The
Narrative mirroring the parallels that
you were able to draw there between her
and Emil I guess that's part of what
perhaps felt like missed out a tad bit
on the narrative for me in the final
episode because don't get me wrong I
enjoy the hell out of it obviously at
the same time I'm like oh but I felt
like you had some interesting actual
narrative setups to play with that were
set up in the beginning in this episode
either way I'm still happy with what we
got there yeah yeah I wouldn't trade it
back we begin the sort of Montage of
Jen's life kind of flopping her mom and
dad hugging her outside of the prison
he's now lost her job and the news is
all over it we have kpv k-15 news Los
Angeles now kzyo12 who called this
galagate like because Gala gay it's a
player on the infamous Watergate we've
seen each news Outlet in earlier
episodes all three appeared in the
beginning of episode 2 covering the Shea
Hulk and Titania courtroom debacle we've
also seen this news track from
consistency same scene of them yelling
to Jen from the window Jen has now moved
out of her Paparazzi apartment after
hearing from what her mom and dad just
said previously I think a I don't think
she can afford it because she has no job
now and B the paparazzi are constantly
hounding her she needs a break we spent
so much time in this home and it's so
sad to see it go like this you don't
even see like with all the other MCU
superheroes this level of obsession
unless you're like Tony Stark or having
some type of Senate meeting
well you're not in L.A is the difference
it's true and when Tony Stark is
surrounded by Paparazzi a lot it is an
Iron Man 3. see boom say say
one gen arrives at her parents house we
see the kcav 35 news van we saw in
episode three a ton of reporters one
looks like the reporter from the third
episode that we've seen as well luckily
Jen's dad is there a great game even
with Morris commenting on not caring if
there's a drought because California is
always in a drought the first thing we
see in Dad's old room is the Legally
Blonde poster which probably is my
favorite Lawyer movie I I'm not joking
thank you Robert says Julia Roberts is
do Roberts Aaron Brockovich movie poster
another Lawyer movie the UCLA Bruins
Banner which yes we do watched that in
school UCLA but in the first episode we
also see her degree so we know she
graduated from it here too some photos
of family and friends of course the
workout equipment her mom left a mancala
game on the Shelf award ribbons A
Midsummer's Night Dream poster with Puck
on the cover Backstreet Boys black and
blue album poster oh yeah baby it's
everyone's old bedroom in our parents
house that they just never touched truly
once we moved out so she was not an
insync girl Sylvia her way into figuring
out big character details
Jesus Christ so we see lion day one Hulk
King Emoji he's the admin around him are
trace phone calls and a post describing
how She-Hulk is a radical why is the
string always red be Ard because how
else is it gonna pop off the the page
even in those like movies where an FBI
agent goes Rogue yeah it's always a red
string when you got such a complicated
case I think sometimes you got to
distinguish you might need different
colored strings to know specifically
like where your eye should go to which
each color should stand for you need the
rainbow 12 pack yeah I'm just saying if
you're gonna go Rogue
you gotta go row you gotta think about
how to easier just the information you
have set up on your board to the left we
see a man whom I assume is a part of the
intelligence yet his middle name is Van
last name
reading number and everything so they've
gone wow that could be a real person
Social Security I know sites and
inevitably made their own right here his
image links to the intelligencia which
links to a black bird-like face a green
sword a moth and a panda a weird Chicken
Boy we know the chicken boy
I think the black one could be the
wizard or Trapster both members of the
intelligence or crossbones the green
moth like one could be Iron moth a
really silly villain in the comics or
Civil War act AKA gypsy moth the panda
icon is
dancing clip the Chicken Boy could be
big from the comics I've mentioned him
in the past I've seen me one of Luke
Jacobson's costume could be from his
episode I love that this could be an
homage to Dick orkin's poop on Comic
Book Heroes from the 60s mainly making
fun of Batman it's green please or they
just made [ __ ] up be Mandrill who has
been problematic in a lot of comics if
you zoom out there's actually a gorilla
or ape at the top so that could also be
mandrel or Gorilla Grodd he is allegedly
owned by several shell companies that
are operating outside of the USD
jurisdiction a shell company is a
company or corporation that exists only
on paper and has bank accounts funding
different assets or just withholding
money we know in season three episode
five of Daredevil fiscu shell
corporations to purchased the hotel he
was staying in and that Julie was
working at sneaky sneaky you remember
Dennis Bukowski right who thought he was
dating
history yeah the idiot now he's on the
conversation with Jefferson Coop who
we've also seen in episode three Dennis
is talking about Jen in their past
relationship being in a relationship
he's clearly lying but not in like a
good way either you just look stupid he
said I blame her grandmother so we know
Jen's mom is Elaine and Elaine's mom is
Beatrice Banner who is married to Robert
Stearns but slept with his brother
Samuel Stearns and then was disavowed by
that brother Robert Stearns it just all
went crazy and Robert ended up killing
his brother so unless he's calling back
to that he knew all that yeah I think
Dennis is just spilling some BS Jen
could be no Dennis was setting up an
even bigger lore with the Walters Banner
family tree right there that's right
season two is gonna bring even more
family members in you're an Easter egg
breakdown Channel don't forget it Jess
it's your job don't disregard any
statement it is all possibly a setup for
the bigger part of the universe
confirmed Jen could be talking to
herself she could be breaking the fourth
wall here when she asks if this is what
we wanted I felt like a child watching
Dora the Explorer going no I'm violently
shaking my head we get the narrator's
like 70s intro coming back and she
acknowledges you can have a narrator
only when you're going off the rails
which is sort of true if you remember
that scene in Emperor's New Groove Jeep
the messages don't go through same with
her text to a mill because they both
don't have service in both places one's
in space and one's on a retreat with no
Wi-Fi Jen goes through her phone and we
see some names like Ethan Rudy Jordan
Robin these people are all people that
could potentially when I look them up
work for different parts in Marvel but I
also think they're just a list of random
names and people that she's dated in the
past like Robin says next time you're in
Vancouver come visit Ken R says fun time
Noah says Darby is the one for you who
we see a clip of in episode three this
could possibly be Darby don't care who
was talking major inches
just Rick Rolling us Rick I just want to
tell you how I see it I think we're just
getting more kind of Rick rolls a lot of
these folks are friends and men that
she's gone on dates with and talked to
briefly so it's just good to mention it
Nikki Upland and Barbara Gordon like a
little dummy in college to the
intelligencia website as bait for the
annoying baby men who hate her if this
doesn't remind you of everyone attacking
AOC when she was dancing in college you
are not catching on baby because this
video is and I quote an epic Find Nikki
immediately gets invited to the Hulk
king of vet happening that night the
same night Jen arrives at emile's
Retreat yeah I edited the She-Hulk
reaction and I
because I was like people are gonna blow
it out of proportion but we made the
full length watch along public they want
to get triggered there anybody wants the
sweet AOC references yeah yeah that's
obviously about that to me it was 100
but if someone said that clip is from
Orphan Black is that the story she was
on yeah
I've never seen it but it could be I've
only seen that clip now I have mostly
see my male mind has only looked good
now I've never seen that clip before
that would at least be a very meta thing
of them to do all right looks like I'm
keeping all politics related comments
and videos so people can obviously while
they're driving on the road
right now
so much I'm like but I spent like hours
on this video on this one there's other
stuff in this that wouldn't come when
Nikki and the whole King are talking
both usernames are not a mouse which is
used when you're not a mouse and a
blouse online forums or just distribute
information super anonymously
anonymously
nicely done idiot welcome from the
record who I expected to be up to
something but as we find out later I
don't think he is not a disappointment
but I was wrong I like admit when I'm
wrong he sets her up I'm a huge Wrecking
Crew fan Neil Blonsky what a Photoshop
job on that cover each of his victims
expressing sorrow so I wonder who
the play the part Nick
I Minaj females because just don't do it
don't do it it's horrible as soon as we
this is my female friend that says big
men you're a good female Jesse is a
motivational posters for a Mill's
Retreat and I'm like seriously even with
the same Obama stay Swag like damn Emil
you don't need their money that bad I
swear to God also this is the same I
didn't notice any of that I know out to
all of those foldable chairs that
She-Hulk threw the record into as pug
listens to a group of idiots
conversation we overhear them already
fighting about the name She-Hulk which
is no surprise there that they don't
recognize a man coined it in the second
episode they also mentioned lady Thor
AKA games
but Valkyrie says he's only been doing
it for a minute so it probably wasn't
that long after but it does confirm that
She-Hulk overlaps with it none other
than the stupid idiot butt face himself
Todd shows up not surprising I think we
all knew that he was a part of the
intelligency I mean he's a butthead I
think we all expected him to be here but
in like the most offensive way he's not
surprised to see pug there and Pug's
heart literally crumbles I'll
Andy's hot a voice in the background
goes yeah I'd smash you and another goes
wait what it killed me I loved it Andy's
hot yeah
what for John that's who plays Todd this
is the most we've got from him in terms
of motivation so Kudos but as Todd I
want to hit him upside this head we see
his Jessica no I hate the actor bring me
John bass's head he was given no credit
which though Todd clearly doesn't know
an ounce of the true story is pissed
about it he also reveals himself to be
Hulk King which no doy we know Todd and
we sort of confirmed Holden Holloway has
nothing wrong or ill wishes upon Jen or
at least as far as the intelligencia
goes because Todd suspects Holden and
Jen are hooking up which gross Todd
winds these guys up and holds him in the
air like an aggressive weird Ted Talk he
will keep that scarf on forever and I
want to choke him with it behind him is
the achieve everything saying Emil has
and a picture of what I assume is a meal
meditating upon a hill silhouetted when
wrecker and Jen are talking Rucker
mentioned Sarah says which is
traditionally for minute tea from China
that's great for lowering your
cholesterol and approving your health
slips in chicken blood because basically
he's a vampire if you remember from
episode seven
hmm
kind of missed the chicken blood peep
The Wrecking Crew in the back right now
maybe I was wrong about wrecker maybe he
left a group rightfully so but his team
is still a part of the intelligencia and
this is the scene we saw from the
trailer of a mil high-fiving all those
men the song playing is gonna be a
winner performed by Jason Glover and
Richard Neal and this does feel like a
life coaching seminar it really does
feel like that when Jen enters I like
that she doesn't care about Todd the men
all weirdly cheering or the event at all
just a meal changing into Abomination
because she's still his lawyer and she
cares about him she's still really his
lawyer I thought she was fired from
everything at that point and after going
to jail and all that nah she's gonna
bust right back in there and be like a
meals pilating his parole she's that
good of a lawyer not even when she's not
a lawyer she still treats her clients as
if they were still her clients that's
right she's gonna go snitch on him this
is about the Integrity of lawyerism I
want to see that movie where instead of
like a cop getting kicked off and then
solving the case the lawyer gets kicked
off still solves the case
that'd be cool
oh well the Pelican Brief there you go
the firm it's Runaway Jury
I don't know what happens
Nikki slams open the garage door
announcing Todd is impact the Hulk King
we learned that Todd paid for Josh to
seduce and steal Jen's blood in episode
seven and his team worked on it
synthesizing it allowing doesn't even
get to see Josh again he takes the blood
it turns into a Hulk taught which is the
most cartoony Scrappy dude hulking out
I've ever seen since the Scooby-Doo
movie Titania arrives again smashing
through a wall and I love Nikki's line
here God does that fish ever use a door
Bruce arrives smashing through the
ceiling and immediately in a
misunderstanding starts fighting a meal
Jen breaks the fourth wall noticing none
of these storylines make sense which is
true everything is popping in out of
everywhere and I swear to God I thought
my computer was conking out when it took
me back to the Disney plus Marvel screen
you guys have to understand that has
happened to us while we're filming and
it's a [ __ ] to sync up yes it is so I
was like
I had that that little voice in the back
of my head like no no no no it's got to
be a fake out It's gotta be a fake hug
it can't be happening I got the finale
especially for our patrons on watchalogs
oh my God damn it I'm sorry guys I
thought I thought I nailed it when I had
to resync brilliant touch though that
was a good fake up and The Sensational
She-Hulk Comics Jen stepped out of the
comic box to start a fight with the
writer which is completely the same not
receiving done on the marble page she
swings from shun chi in the ten rings to
Loki and jumps into Marvel assembled
which is funny because now it's
featuring a thumbnail of Thor love and
thunder but at the time She-Hulk was
imposed probably featuring Sean Chi this
is when it goes off the rails because
she now knows the other shows and movies
that appear on Disney plus she's aware
of her story being a portion of a larger
threat either way we're brought to the
Disney lot in Burbank California once
Jen landed on set we saw all this bit in
the trailer but they edited out all the
Productions
also two men are discussing the first
Thor movie and having to make thanos's
Gauntlet during the first Thor movie
refers to the fake one that we saw the
Disney water tower the Seven Dwarves
holding up the roof the old wise tale is
that the Seven Dwarfs are holding up the
roof because that's what kind of started
Disney that was like the first feature
film for Disney still keeping it
together middle of the courtyard along
with the two on the bench the Disney
Legends hand prints all over the walls
of different artists we see our weekly
QR code on the She-Hulk door it takes
you to a free copy of The Sensational
She-Hulk 1989 issue number 50 also peep
the Captain America poster in the back
the same one we've seen in the first
Captain America movie but these posters
are telling you to silence your phones
which I think is really funny and in an
amazing yeah
and oh my God this is fun this was also
Kevin feige's idea we have the Captain
America poster slightly different crafty
snacks on the wall are different types
of photos for Titania and LeapFrog we
see a man bull the demons portrayed in
the fourth episode on the Whiteboard it
says finale with a four-leaf clover now
recently I found out that all the words
on the Whiteboard are things that Zeb
Wells says during pitching in the
writer's room so they just put all the
favorite phrases that he said on that
wall so all of these lists are just
things that Zeb has said who's aka the
ham guy and the credits I'll get into
that in a second he I guess coined
enchettable Hulk which we see at the
wedding episode in episode 6 all over
Chad's shirt in the DJ equipment
Nanobots Exclamation point Exclamation
point and the comics Iron Man injected
She-Hulk with Nanobots that inhibit her
power things like here you're not
allergic to wowies but there's no wowie
at the end which could refer to our big
climax as being wowies gamma goo but I
think I like it more if it's kind of
like gabagool and it's gamma ghoul
closed captioning not available
Nexus millions of times before and the
Marvel's Cinematic Universe see I heard
a while ago that Reddit leaks that Modoc
like like 99 of those Reddit leaks
didn't come true but there was like
people were really convinced that Modoc
would show up like I don't know why but
all right this happened and McCoy
pointed out we were watching he's like
he's Modoc like oh I wonder if this is
what maybe they heard about and thought
it was Modoc probably I could definitely
see that because it's the kind of thing
where through the game of telephone I
could absolutely imagine it warping into
that pretty easily yeah apparently the
print came in fighting the show do you
mean Modoc yeah definitely we followed
Jen through the Marvel Studios Corridor
and elevator and this space like
wallpaper you can see the a Marvel
studio sign behind it but opposite of
the elevator is actually the Guardians
of the Galaxy I want to see like an
Aaron Sorkin drama of uh
okay getting into it with the Marvel
Studios just her going in and arguing
like entertainment law with them and
also how this should be written how the
show should be done yeah how to secure
the rights for certain things they want
to do come on Aaron sorry can get to
work on the real projects you wanted to
actually entertainment law idea is not a
bad call he loves like courtroom stuff
yeah
it would be a match made it happen in a
lot of ways it really would like they
would have to give him free reign but
that would be so exciting it could be
like a meta entertainment lawyer the
Marvel Network that should be your
special presentation you see a black
panther poster next to the She-Hulk
poster and the office waiting area we
see a Hulk statue The Infinity Gauntlet
various Marvel action figures including
the tiny Thanos on his little chair on
the table we see Tony Stark's suits his
Mark two five and seven suits the
receptionist is actually played by Matt
Wilkie who at the time worked as Marvel
Studios as the receptionist because they
thought it would be fun for you to be
like that's the guy that actually signed
me in and told me to sign the NBA
speaking of ndas you have the size you
did a good job he's an aspiring actor
Marvel dude they're not gonna let you
leak their secrets without signing the
NDA then Q energy by lotto and We're Off
to the Races baby Jen is beating up
every Marvel security Personnel in her
way I like this hallway fighting scene
because it's giving me Daredevil
fighting scene and I'm like ooh they're
getting closer he gave me black widow
Iron Man two fighting all the Marvel
references concept art we see rocket and
Star-Lord from Guardians of the Galaxy
Thor's hammer and the Arc Reactor from
Iron Man once we make it to Kevin's
let's call it an office we see clips
from Civil War Infinity War Multiverse
and Madness black panther Thor Ragnarok
end game Avengers separately Age of
Ultron some of these clips show up in
the opening sequence to a Marvel movie
but not all of them and in a spooky
reveal we find out Kevin is a robot a
very smart sentient robot that's been
creating these Marvel shows and movies
also his hood for his camera eyes it
looks like a hat
no way I did not catch that oh damn the
Hat great detail he needs a Kevin hat
also I know that people want Jon Hamm to
play Mr Sinister so let's just leave it
at that this reveal completely reminded
me of the Wally scene when we realized
the robot was actually crazy and very
evil I also really like this gag that
She Hulk has been going on sort of
poking fun at Marvel things in an
interview Jessica gow said that they had
to cut a lot of their jokes out of the
series because they poke too much fun at
Marvel but making Kevin feigen an
all-powerful all-knowing robot that the
writers obey and pray to is funny and
true to all of us and Kevin is built so
interestingly he has three lenses each
red blue green RGB primary colors of
light used in a lot of video formats
color TV even he has two sort of floppy
disk drives upon his head which is why
and on and off switch which I'm sure is
not in use the screen on the side I can
make out says Kevin but I think it's
tracking which lens it's using either
way it's font and format kind of looks
like the TV's used in Loki oh yeah you
can get into a wider view you see the
film reels continuously spinning
and Kevin acknowledges the VFX is
expensive citing gen must change off
screen so easy so fun though he does go
off and say that the VFX artists have
moved on to different projects when he
says that we hear the wakanda drums
indicating it was probably to move those
VFX folks over to the wakanda forever
during the time of shooting this I mean
or it's a nod to The Plight that the VFX
Folks at Disney whom they usually
Outsource have been dealing with for a
while being overworked and underpaid I
calls it as a season I feel like it was
a compromise yes they couldn't say the
full full truth but they could say some
of the truth they couldn't be like our
VFX artists are overworked so we can't
do it because they're lazy bums why do
we pay them because they're just they
don't do their slave labor handle the
grind someone else will for cheaper
sad but true we also get shots of these
podiums filled with different Marvel
comic books it feels like Kevin is sort
of absorbing them the bottom of the
podiums look like electric currents
though it could actively be always
reading these Comics I'm no Ryan Airy I
never would say
sure went in depth on each of these
Comics right
but he didn't get the RGB until after a
She-Hulk comic book and a Scarlet Witch
we got the Miss Marvel Captain America
The Incredible Hulk and Daredevil shun
Chi and I think that's Sam Wilson's
Captain America what I do sort of like
is that as opposed to most MCU movies or
shows that have these giant climaxes
with explosions fights and sometimes the
super soldiers theorem this could be the
first to break that deal with the
internal conflict that Jed has while
everyone else's Stakes may include
rampaging and Powers Jens is fighting
herself and overcoming all that stuff
that happened to her so yeah different
Stakes can work and I like that Kevin
took that into account I hope every
Marvel property ends this way now this
is the new one I hope when Sherry pops
up against Neymar shot and then name
Wars like this isn't how I want our
fight to end and then he breaks the
fourth wall yeah it flies out with his
little wing feet and then they like both
go to the Marvel HQ everyone's expecting
a big finale don't you think the Latin
culture and the African-American culture
should get along even though they are
African and not African-American so stop
saying they're African-American Kevin
Kevin you should be making these
decisions I think you're spread a little
thin so now Todd's Hulk powers are
removed Holt does not save the day and
Jen's show but Jen does interject and
say save it for the movie which every
avenger who has a family has now gained
like a movie there's like Thor argue
Wanda and now a whole and I don't think
it's necessarily A get a child get a
movie deal but we need to see our
Avengers that haven't died move on as we
introduce some newer ones coming in as
Jen is addressing her needs I love that
Kevin begins to acknowledge that some
can see as a fault on the MCU for being
light in that department referring to
sex Jen immediately sits down and starts
listing all her quarrels after that and
I love it all the petty issues I.E Loki
Thor Tony Stark Star-Lord arguably
Gamora and nebula oh for sure the list
literally does go on she's team audience
looking out for us asking when the X-Men
are coming he says he can't answer that
right now I like what she's doing here
with the thumbs up and the tongue out
like a silly goose
which is a great way to lean into
getting a new season Once you just
address it and say it out loud maybe you
might get it you know they need to know
also keep in mind Bruce May smash
buildings but Jen smashes Bad Endings
and Matt Murdock this right this is
right we're back at a Mills Retreat and
it's daylight outside all the men that
stayed from the Intelligentsia Meetup
event is now arrested the LA sheriff
department is there probably because
this is out of LA's City's jurisdiction
so it's not the LAPD it's the LA sheriff
department and the dodc is there for a
mill Titania is of course blogging
everything to her titaniacs and we still
presumably don't know why she's there
later with her parents introducing Matt
to everyone our Jen and Matt dating soon
to be I don't know but I love this Bruce
arrives I love it son and this is Scar
and Scar has arrived my dudes I was the
one that said I don't think he's gonna
be showing up look who's here standing
behind his dad like a sad sad brooding
child scar is played by Will Do's wow
okay theories people had about scar in
the series and what might possibly
follow the world war whole storyline now
in the comics during Planet Hope was
vanished off Earth and he landed on his
car and met Kyra the old straw they had
a son Scar and now before kyera's death
she created cocoon for scar to keep him
safe in which he emerges from not long
after this happened while Hulk was
already on his way back to Earth to
enact revenge for banishing him off
world scar aged quickly after coming out
of that damn cocoon but as soon as he
emerged he came out of fighter because
that's all he knew and Son of Hulk he
goes after axemen bone Galactus fights
his cousin She-Hulk even going after
Hulk and Son of Hull he likes to fight
you guys he just fights I don't think
we'll necessarily see all of that but I
think we could get something wrong not
being there for him and this is all the
aftermath of that we're back outside the
field reporter that coined the name
she-hulks stop Jen for questioning and
we see the courtroom illustration of Jen
stepping and looking back mirrored here
it's also a nod to the dance lot
She-Hulk comic heavy spoilers before
this episode aired said he thought this
would be the very last scene I saw that
he dude Kevin spoilers knows what he's
talking about nailed it I like that she
says that if you attack harm or harass
innocent people I'm coming for you and
when asked as a superhero lawyer she
says both and I can't wait to see Jen
prosecute by Dan Kick Ass by Night the
show of Missy Elliott's we run this
Jen's literally running this changed her
own ending girl like who does that of
the irony that's like she changed her
own ending but really Kevin feige still
approved it yeah she had to sell him on
the chase she was lucky he listened
otherwise the show would have been
canceled before the episode was over
we've got a couple new courtroom
illustrations there's princess silk
feather wearing a meals inhibitor Kevin
wearing his signature baseball cap
reading she-hulk's first issue Jen
taking Todd to court with low down dirty
Josh sweating behind She-Hulk we also
get our final mid-credits scene and it's
Wong breaking a mill out of prison so
now we can expect to see a meal and
America Chavez at the karmitage I would
have killed to see Madison in the
background but you know I'll take it as
is also a meal she's the Wi-Fi password
just like strange ass mordo in the first
Doctor Strange movie oh what's this my
mantra
the Wi-Fi password
we're not Savages and that's everything
I spotted in the ninth episode of
She-Hulk follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at Lulu underscore Clemens while
a new rock star subscribe to new
rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love I've had a blast
literally so much fun breaking these
down for you lawyers
oh God I'm choking and I'll have a blast
breaking down whatever comes my way next
so don't worry I'll be back I hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching She-Hulk
Smith
oh yeah killed it you you smashed it
Jess now it's time to break down that
new movie starring Julia Roberts and
George Clooney about that divorce couple
who was trying to break up their
daughter's wedding because they don't
think she should be getting married but
maybe in the process of trying to break
up their relationship they're gonna
rekindle their romance what they're
gonna get together along the way
realizing that they were wrong the whole
time about what they were doing to their
own daughter comes out Halloween
surprisingly yes we need a a good
wholesome alternative to all that
violence and Candy anyway looking
forward to that breakdown you did a
great job on this whole series you're an
absolute Delight
absolute Delight alrighty
um yeah subscribe to new rockstars and
let's do a patreon
Gabriel okay Gabriel so we decided to go
you know what oh we're gonna look up a
Gabriel in Marvel so we have this from
Marvel fandom Earth 616 typed in
specifically who is Gabriel in Marvel
I'm expecting something entirely
different here we go Gabriel was an
angel from heaven and an archangel oh
wow okay couldn't see that coming all
right yeah yeah look I'm sure it's
different than what we normally
especially the ancient hero with here we
go here we go he notoriously appeared to
Mary when she was about to marry Joseph
of Nazareth
and told her the Holy Spirit would come
upon her and the holy child shall be
called the son of God
so cool dude so Marvel created the Bible
Kevin must have approved to the pages of
the Bible I mean God goes through me God
God answers to someone and his name is
Kevin we answered a God but who just got
it from God's mouth to Kevin from from
God's mouth to my ears but really from
Kevin's mouth to God's ears to God's
mouth to might I was trying to give you
a different meaning than you know what
normally happens but okay here we go
Gabriel Here We Go you can ignite or
disintegrate any object or Thing by
touch see you can kill thing from the
Fantastic Four now uh that means you
have an insane ability and I hope that
you can um do this to some other
reaction channels that we don't like
surely terminate their Channel kill him
and then we could laugh gloriously melt
them as they go off about her on Twitter
improve your loyalty as a super sexy to
reject Gabriel by igniting and
disintegrating any YouTube channel we
desire yeah that would be a big old
could you come bless me please wow that
was a really good fake sneeze John I
just wanted to capitalize on the whole
Angelic that was being such good
physical acting because also what it
says here is that he has the ability to
purify Souls of those affected by demons
and as we all know sneezing lets in the
demons
so I acted that sneeze for for to
illustrate that
all right
[Music]